finding the beauty in two opposing views
well i like to call that the pretty
little middle
aka balance balance is where two halves
make a hole and one area this is
particularly important
parenting helping us today is my good
friend
friend of the show and parenting
educator dr aliza pressman
she's the co-founding director of the
mount sinai parenting center
and she has a podcast called raising
good humans she's one prestigious lady
dr eliza thank you for being here hello
let me just come out of the gate and ask
you
what are some of the main issues that
parents can't seem to agree on
anything that pulls up your childhood
memory of being parented which is
basically discipline
your parenting styles are reflected in
discipline things that
things related to boundary setting i
know a couple going through it
rachel and brad are happily married
parents of three
but here's a look at what's happening in
their house drew this is a perfect
example
i literally just made the kids a real
fruit smoothie
and then brad gets home from work and
he's giving them packaged fruit snacks
[Music]
that kind of stuff drives me crazy i
want to make sure
that the twins don't get hungry because
if they do
then it's meltdown city sometimes it
takes a while to cut up
fresh fruit but you're just not sure
that they're gonna eat them
nine times out of ten when i get home
from work and brad's already with the
kids they're on their tablets
so let's just see
[Music]
hey guys welcome home hey
what you doing junebug
it's educational sometimes i need to get
things done
i'm not above using screen time to
occupy the children
it is very frustrating for me when i'm
the only one that's
trying to make an effort to make dinner
time
a nice family conversation
[Music]
when it's time to sit down for dinner
i'm just tired
all day i'm telling them what they can
what they can't do i just want to sit
down
have a nice meal with my wife and not
have to yell at the kids
and when i say yell not have to tell the
kids what they can
and they can't do
brad and baseball thank you for joining
us from lake ozark missouri
and being here with us thanks for coming
on this show
thank you for having us yeah we need
some help so
rachel do you feel really like the kids
see you as the bad cop
oh for sure um and i try i feel like i'm
with the kids
by myself more often than he is when
he's home we're both around so
i feel like what i do um there's just
more pressure on what i do
and i feel like since i've been the
disciplinarian all day i'll wait
for him to sort of step in when he gets
home and do some disciplining
and it just seems like it doesn't
necessarily happen so
to the kids it's just like i'm the
disciplinarian and he's the fun one
well and then from my perspective you
know i have a full-time job
i'm also in the navy reserves so i'm
gone one week in a month two weeks a
year
so i'm just not home a lot and so you
know i don't want to come home
and then just be the disciplinary for
the children
you know i want you know i want them to
like me
of course because i'm not around as much
elisa let me ask you a question
do you think kids see them that black
and white as good cop bad cop
i love that question because what brad
just said when he said
i want them to like me that's an there's
an assumption that they're not going to
like you because you give them
boundaries or have some expectation of
their behavior
but we don't actually know what another
human being is thinking and so it's a
really good opportunity to say
maybe they feel really safe because
there are boundaries and there's
some sense of what is expected of them
but with sensitivity and kindness and a
sense of humor so there's a way to do
both of those things and be
liked by your kids you're still their
guide not their buddy
and so you can have both of those but it
makes so much sense if you feel like
well i'm not there very much
i want them to like me so i just want to
also straighten that out your kids will
have respect for you and feel safe
when you create certain predictable
boundaries but also
have time for fun and you don't need to
be so attached
to every one of those rules so on the
other side of it
letting go and saying the world is not
going to end if we have a little bit of
a crazy night
it might be that you still go to bed on
time or you do whatever it is that's
like the bigger picture
of the boundaries but the little details
don't matter so much
already your tone with each other isn't
negative you can really provoke an
emotion
with a certain tone of the way you're
saying things
and you guys seem like a really strong
happy couple
and i think what you're going through is
just really typical and we
we get it yeah um we really
try to actively put our marriage first
and be parents second even though it's
not really
um i don't know it just it's not easy to
do at this stage you know because our
twins are two and a half and we have a
10 month old
daughter so it's not easy to put each
other first
and you know then take care of the
children so well eliza
you used a certain word and it was
shaming when you make people feel
ashamed for the
approach of sort of trying to figure out
your differences
please talk to that yeah when you when
you jump into
criticizing each other and shaming each
other about your parenting style
all that really does is take us into a
fight flight or freeze mode
that's just a stress response that
anybody gets so
what's great is if you are putting your
marriage first
you're removing or at least can try to
remove
the judgment the shame so it's not about
i'm doing this right you're doing this
wrong
it's about let's figure out how to do
this in a way that is comfortable for
both of us
since we come from totally different
approaches
also you guys said that every time you
come home
i heard sort of like there's a setup
there's a dynamic where you're expecting
it
to go a certain way it inevitably does
and that might be a letdown
and i think what i'd love to figure out
is how we change that
you